how to become a better tactical player
for me as it's it's so confusing because
I think it's very easy to conflate two
things that are actually very different
from each other one is the creativity to
be able to look at all sorts of
different candidate moves including ones
I wouldn't come to most humans like my
mom's beautiful Queen before stuff like
that or there's also just the brute
force calculation of being able to see
accurately 10 moves ahead and all the
different counter moves oftentimes it's
not ten moves but rather five or six but
seeing all the different sub variations
and to me they're actually like really
different they're not always you might
be terrible at one and good at the other
right Wow
okay so tactics calculation and
combinations right so some people see
tactics very very quickly so tactics we
think in terms of short-term
opportunities and just pattern
recognition right you just see a double
attack and another double attack and
another double attack that leads you to
this winning position and then you see a
combination which as you say there's the
initiation as a sacrifice and then
there's a series of good defensive moves
assuming they play all the good
defensive moves and they don't go for
the bad defensive moves then comes with
another sacrifice and this combination
seems to go on and further and further
and suddenly you're being pressing the
limits of your ability to calculate a
variation but you're riding a tiger and
it feels right so each time you're
making the sacrifice not necessarily
seeing the end of the game as being a
win for you necessarily but you feel
like you you're doing the right thing
that you that you're seize the
initiative and you're pressing right so
the question is how do you improve and
how do you get to that level where
instinctively you're finding the right
ideas right well that's where your
pattern recognition comes in and some of
these tactics you keep seeing
surface again and again and again and
again and that just playing through
these puzzle books these tactics and
recently I have to confess a little bit
of a I'm not gonna say obsession because
that's really too much but I like the
puzzle rush I do like the challenge that
it provides and it's stimulating right
you're you're improving it
self-improvement you're trying to
improve your score right like I'm
usually in the very low 40s to the high
30s before I strike three or something
but today thanks to computers we can
improve our tactics so much what do you
like to do Jennifer well one thing I
recommend is that puzzle rush and doing
tactics one whatever online server it's
very important but I also think that if
you're hitting a wall like say you keep
doing it and you're not getting past 40
or 35 or 30 or whatever it is now maybe
you need to switch it up do some tactics
using a regular board and pieces or look
at a book I think all the different kind
of dimensions are really important and
you know Grandmaster hynerian a crush
who has lots of students says that
that's proven really important and her
work with students that she see notices
that if they only do it in the computer
so they say they'll two-dimensional
screen and not 3d this world picking up
a piece and you might yeah absolutely my
brother of the u.s. chesticles said the
same thing that it's kind of important
to mix it up a little and then also I
think that it's not only about that
pattern recognition it's also about just
testing yourself in the sometimes
unpleasant work of calculating really
deep and that comes into you know
looking at pinang games and maybe
writing down your analysis and then
checking it against the reality I also
think looking at the games of very
inspiring attacking players like Garry
Kasparov and Judit Polgar stopping at a
tactical position and testing urinalysis
with their analysis right I really was
very moved by some of juda poll gars
annotated games in her series of
and what moved me was some of the tricks
so it was also about the mastery of
psychology magnus carlsen a Judit Polgar
not only having the tactics but kind of
anticipating what their opponent might
do that would lead to an unexpected
trick right uncorking something that's
really a surprise and and knowing the
surprises there you're almost reminding
me of garry kasparov and his opening
novelties they're not necessarily
tactical but the element of surprise
playing a crucial part so when you do
tactical puzzles and stuff do you look
at the whole game of a judeth polgár or
Garry Kasparov or you only drilling down
to a specific position if you use one of
their books oftentimes you can kind of
cheat a little bit because they just get
to that good moment you can go through
it a little bit quicker and then there's
like a diagram that shows you that maybe
there's gonna be like a long series of
analysis right only I mean obviously
it's fantastic to look at the whole game
but I know that a lot of our viewers are
pressed for time so they're looking for
high-density learning right and in that
case you don't always have time to look
at the whole game but III think that
it's all about mixing it up a little bit
especially if you know you hit a lot
right just like an exercise right you do
the exactly the same thing for six
months and you're not seeing any results
right time to mix it up very good and in
terms of digital software any particular
I think my wife Yvette she likes chess
mom she likes this just tactics and I
remember Rachel
yes this frog they shoot that the it was
this tactical game where she's jumping
with a frog across these lilies on the
pond and she was just like mesmerised
and she was beating me he's like did she
did it recently yeah recently she made a
us mad chess master at the age of ten or
nine right I mean just absolutely
incredible so there are a lot of ways to
roam when it
tactics exactly thing but you just have
to keep mixing it up keep working at it
and you know believe in yourself believe
that you can get better at calculation
and tactics no matter what age you're at
it also comes to that self belief and
yeah we wish you guys lots of luck but
if you're watching us on broadcast one
way to improve your tactical vision is
turn your own engine off of course
sometimes Maurice is gonna pop in and
give us an engine analysis but try to
test yourself at least in some points in
the broadcast so you don't know
immediately that somebody blender
exactly and again I love what you've
just said test yourself against the
player try to guess what Magnus is going
to play on the next move or in even if
you don't absolutely guess accurately
try to guess what the candidate moves
might be excellent and then you'll be on
your way to tactical wizardry and chess
master